>>> OH, MY GOD.
THESE MEETINGS TONIGHT HAVE BEEN
BRUTAL.
>> I KNOW.
I CAN BARELY KEEP MY EYES OPEN.
>> YOU GUYS, I AM SO DONE WITH
JANET.
>> OKAY, SHE IS AWFUL.
>> I KNOW.
>> SHE'S ALWAYS RUNNING DOWN THE
HALLWAY SO FAST.
IT'S LIKE WHAT'S THE BIG RUSH,
JANET?
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY DO ANYTHING.
>> I KNOW.
AND DOES SHE HAVE TO EAT TUNA
EVERY DAY?
>> MAKES ME SICK.
AND SHE CHEWS WITH HER MOUTH
OPEN LIKE A FARM ANIMAL.
>> YES.
>> OKAY, THE WORST IS WHEN SHE'S
QUIET.
IT'S SO CREEPY.
SERIOUSLY.
LIKE YESTERDAY WHEN WE WERE CAR
POOLING,
I COMPLETELY FORGOT SHE WAS IN
THE CAR BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T SAY A
WORD THE WHOLE TIME.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN SHE JUST
POPS UP IN THE BACK SEAT OUT OF
NOWHERE LIKE CHUCKY.
[ TOILET FLUSHES ]
>> HEY, CHUCKY.
>> WE DIDN'T REALIZE YOU WERE IN
THERE.
>> WELL, I WAS.
>> DID YOU HEAR US TALKING?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
ONLY THE PART WHERE YOU COMPARED
ME TO JANET, YOU FILTHY SLUTS!
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MESS WITH
ME!
>> NOW, I KNOW NO ONE LIKES
GETTING CALLED INTO AN HR
MEETING, BUT GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED
THIS MORNING, I FELT IT WAS
NECESSARY.
CHUCKY, AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
COMPANY POLICY AGAINST STABBING
YOUR COWORKERS IN THE LEGS WITH
A KNIFE.
BUT LADIES, WE ALSO HAVE A
ZERO-TOLERANCE POLICY WHEN IT
COMES TO BULLYING.
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT CHUCKY WAS
UNCALLED FOR.
ESPECIALLY COMPARING HIM TO
JANET.
WHO WE ALL KNOW SUCKS.
>> I'M SORRY, WHY DO I HAVE TO
BE HERE?
>> TO TAKE NOTES, JANET.
>> OKAY, SO HOW CAN WE STOP THIS
KIND OF THING FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FUTURE?
>> BY PUTTING THESE BITCHES IN
BODY BAGS?
>> SEE, THAT'S IT RIGHT THERE.
CHUCKY'S ALWAYS SAYING THINGS
LIKE THAT.
>> I ALSO THINK THESE
GENDER-NEUTRAL BATHROOMS WERE A
BIG MISTAKE.
>> UH-OH.
>> ONLY BECAUSE NOW I HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT CHUCKY DROPPING DOWN
FROM THE CEILING AND LANDING ON
MY BACK WHILE I'M SITTING ON THE
TOILET.
>> DON'T TEMPT ME WITH A GOOD
TIME.
>> EW, CHUCKY, STOP.
>> CHUCKY, I UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN YOUR FEELINGS GET HURT,
YOUR FIRST INSTINCT IS VIOLENCE.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU'RE STABBING ME
IN THE LEG RIGHT NOW.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> YOU SEE, HE DOESN'T BELONG
HERE.
>> YES, HE DOES.
♪♪
EACH OF US HAS A DIFFERENT
STORY.
MEGAN, YOU HAVE A BACKGROUND IN
PR.
PEGGY, YOU WERE IN THE MILITARY.
AND CHUCKY, YOU DID AN ANCIENT
VOODOO CURSE THAT WHEN COMBINED
WITH A LIGHTNING STRIKE
TRANSFERRED YOUR SOUL TO THE
BODY OF A DOLL.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NO ONE
ELSE HERE CAN SAY.
>> HE'S NOT EVEN LISTENING.
>> YOW WOW WOW WOW WOW WOW WOW!
>> WELL, I THINK WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS.
>> LOOK!
OH MY GOD!
JANET!
ARE YOU EATING TUNA RIGHT NOW?
>> WHAT?